anybody want to be inside me we're gonna
go into experimental mode because I have
no idea what its gonna be and there's a
stupid name
mark it mark if market FARC market for
it that's oppose me I guess all right
mark apart Mike Rivard is on the
experimental server I have no idea what
that means
I don't know what the experimental modes
are but I'm on North American servers
under the name Marco fart really cool
music I guess the IRS wanted to come
after me
no no oh god it's really fast is this
faster than usual this is really fast
okay alright then so I remember I mark a
fart on the experimental service and I
do all know what that means
I don't know what that means Gary thank
you mark oh man I really don't know if
this is any different what what what is
what are the experiment can someone tell
me what the experimental servers do like
what happens on them thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you what do
they do
what do they do hey I'm right here eat
me mark he moves let me eat you I'm
right here I'm right here I'm right here
let me eat you give me give it look
boobs oh come on you let boobs eat eat
me mark EMU god dammit there's no
loyalty among here thank you Mark a fart
mark fart
mark mark here - right mark fart oh
my god troll face troll face scary scary
troll face oh come on you guys come on
it's me it's mark fart mark avert come
on man mark fart you know market fart
man
weird apart boys you gotta use markup
art market flower man let's work hard
all of the not upon eyes 4000 come on
mark apart
hmm look about here right here
oh no you guys didn't help me they
didn't help me they could have helped
and they didn't please let me die
let's go ahead mark afar back into the
action mark fart shooting up the sides
mark fart being all sneaky mark of art
hello mark of art here mark for our dear
smart mert mert mert mark for bargain
hard mark bars back pocket hearts come
back work hearts gonna eat the USA not
about eyes oh boy thank you mark apart
thank you
is that for me stubborn I'm dumb not
going for that
chilly willy up lol help thank you get
rekt mark no you you will be the one
that gets rekt I shall be the one that
wrecks you well maybe not no thank you
get rekt you want to wreck me huh okay
never mind just be on with it oh oh what
is that what is that what is that what
is that I have no idea what that is
thank you what is this that's so cool
Marga farts you're a liar mark of art
you're a fake Marky farter your fake
market fart fake mark yeah that's right
the real Barca fart is blue court mark
fart mark that's not even trying give me
your poor if you see the mark apart
thrust your body upon me thrust your
body all over me oh boy mark van Marga
parts here mark mark come on give me
your body give me your body
give me your buddy I don't know why I'm
being a dick now or no you guys can have
your own fun it's okay I understand it's
all right it's all good that's all good
it's all good
Marga fart yay yay yay yay yay yay yay
yay yay yay I feel good I feel welcome
oh my god this is much better
oh this is so much better oh so much
better oh I've already on the
leaderboard oh boy
oh boy don't worry I shall protect all
of you thank you thank you very much
thank you
all right that's really cool it's like
it's a food pellet dispenser
there's only do it in like random spurts
or something I have no idea
oh there's so many people here I want to
eat them all want to eat them all gonna
eat all of them what are you oh oh my
already a 3000 oh yeah give me yeah
that's right yeah you want some of this
huh anybody want some anybody want to be
inside me good do a bit baby oh no that
wasn't for me those trying to survive
I'm a jerk I'm a jackass I'm a jackass
I feel bad I don't feel bad I don't feel
bad at all
I kind of feel bad I feel a little bad
but not that bad I feel kind of bad I'm
a bit of a jerk I'm a bit of a jerk I'm
a bit of a jerk mark of Arts number two
mark of Arts best go on market Fargo go
mark of art there's so many people here
how in the world is this possible jeez
feed me your bodies feed me your bodies
feed me hey mate anybody want to feed me
feed me feed me feed me feed me thank
you thank you thank you be hyper p-type
knows what's up
he doesn't want to be squashed by
hashtag eggplant hashtag Pete hug all
the way oh no oh well I don't care what
you think you can beat me huh I will eat
you I'll eat all of you eat you know you
made a mistake
Barbara you made a mistake yeah that's
right
maybe stick made a big mistake I'm the
best here on the winner I'm the winner
no no it's actually a lot more fun just
because of how many more people there
are here it's insanity this is so many
people how in the world this is possible
that's so crazy
and how is it possible without ain't
lack I've played on servers with like
two people and its unending lag there's
also way more of the virus spheres oh
man is so cool oh my me just
here need our crap that happened
well done matter what do you think you
think YouTube my bro huh huh huh no the
answer is no someone give me stuff I
need stuff I need a lot of stuff I need
stuff really hard to survive here just
because of how many like virus fears
there I might be in trouble guys I'm
surrounded by virus fears s5 I have no
idea no goddamn idea it's gonna stay
right here it's gonna stay right here
simply a pretty safe lie
yeah oh my me just big old mark fart
here floating where I don't belong
oh no Tom Cruise come for my mark of
heart no Tom Cruise no holy you I will
eat all of you ah I got you Tom Cruise
ha market fart wins work for Wednesday
work for is the best because you want
somebody you want mark apart ok for you
come yeah someone give me some I'm gonna
give me some don't get me marklar Marv
we're gonna win the day marker work for
mark on actually surprise a chat on
YouTube Habsburg there's like a few
advantages from YouTube that I've seen
versus twitch and that's what one is
like the chat hasn't like completely
broken which is good I guess you guys
want you guys want to be part of the
market part you mark a fan you shall be
assimilated into the market hard you
shall be assimilated
you gonna be assimilated whether you
like it or not you'll be assimilated oh
you oh you acting like you don't want it
oh come on
dogs get God thread the needle go down
go down go down go down
thread the needle through me thread the
needle through my butt crack good job
yeah yeah yeah there you go you're good
you're good you're good what don't go
back up the other guy got eaten you're
fine that's awesome
hey hey fight but you're stepping on my
markup and he's my buddy
it's my bro he's my bro
you think we mess with my bro art fans
in my bosom the bosom on my butt cheeks
or the safest part could possibly be I
think everyone is just waiting or
hanging around me waiting for me to
screw up but everyone's still feeding me
smooth it's even better
uh-huh uh-huh worse - you got big gonna
have you are you going into me oh you're
so nice I'm gonna sandwich all these
guys up here just see oh no oh no I
think no I think I'm still fine exid Lee
I think I'm actually totally fine hmm
yeah it seems it seemed to be okay
wonder what would happen I bet I can get
oh oh oh look at me twenty thousand oh
good my mark efforts
oh my mark averts all federal thinks
he's so cool we can't beat me well it
could be me if you come near me don't a
plan escape beta everyone thrusts their
bodies upon me everybody I popped Delta
plan uber mensch before
gefilte fish oh god no everything's gone
awry everything's got horribly horribly
wrong I seem to be losing I seem to have
lost God I keep hitting all the fire
I guess I'll make my great sacrifice by
popping all these virus fears that
everyone else seems to be ignoring me
III hit problems head-on everyone else
just wants to ignore them look at this
look at what you've done everybody
you've made mark a fart loose mark of
hearts a loser because of all of you
you made mark a fart lose look at this
look at me now look at me now mark of
heart is a shell of his former self
wonder what you've all done look at what
you have wrought what you have wrought
oh really really not up in eyes really
really not of a knife really oh really
oh really oh oh oh oh really oh really
oh really oh oh you're gonna be like
that
I hope you understand what happens when
you inhale the market fart
Cory you got